today marks 12 weeks since we passed the
heroes act
in the house of representatives a bill
to open up our economy by testing
tracing treatment
mask sanitation distancing and the rest
that honored our heroes so called
because they are
risking their lives to save lives and
now they may be losing their jobs in
fact a million and a half had
that will have already that would be our
healthcare workers our
our first responders our teachers our
sanitation
transportation food workers who are all
employees of state and local government
to meet the needs of the american people
one and a half million already at least
have been
laid off going on to unemployment that's
not a savings
and it is a disservice to to their
constituents
it also there's projected to be 3.6
million more laid off in the in the
weeks ahead
unless we do something to protect our
heroes we lose
all moral authority to praise them to
thank them
and then say but we don't want to spend
money to have you keep your job
and then third to put money in the
pockets of the american people
it's about the lives the livelihood
and the life of our democracy so we have
some concerns about
census postal service protection of our
elections
safety in the workplace with osha and
the rest so
in that time in that 12 weeks that you
remember that right then and there when
we passed the bill
the republican leader in the senate said
he was going to
we needed a pause so he pushed the pause
button he pushed the pause button and in
that period of time
in these 12 weeks about three and a half
million people have been infected added
to the roles
of those infected 70 milli
excuse me 70 000 have died
70 000 and uh twelve weeks
three and three and a half million in
fact
and then last week he comes back finally
from the pause
uh with a piecemeal proposal that does
not meet the needs of the american
people
as you know we have been mightily trying
to find common ground with our
colleagues it's hard when your
values are so different in terms of
bubble up from the working class
families
instead of trickle down from above
yesterday i offered to them we'll take
down
a trillion if you add a trillion
in they said absolutely not
if we could do that if we take down a
trillion and they add a trillion we'll
be within range
we'll be within range but we must meet
the needs of the american people
we could come down some because we can
change the dates of exploration the rest
of that
but not undermine our priorities to meet
the needs of the american people
and it is we're in a big different place
again we believe in science
and governance in terms of addressing
that
the virus that we need to do and that's
how we're going to open
our economy uh in terms of livelihoods
um
we're honoring our heroes that it
doesn't do anything
for our economy to have more people on
unemployment
especially when they are our heroes safe
schools we're in a different place
because
we are listening to
what is happening in communities where
they're telling us largely they want to
have
uh virtual
the hundred top the largest uh
school districts so over 60 said they're
going to have
all virtual some a hybrid
a very few actually in person schooling
we want as many kids as possible to go
to school
but we have to make it safe for them to
do so
and then we have housing insecurity
we have food insecurity the list goes on
and on
i wrote to my colleagues about this
today you've probably seen that
so this is about i see everything
through the eyes of the children
their food insecurity their housing
insecurity
we can't have our children be hungry we
can't have them be
uh homeless and we cannot have them be
afraid
to go to school and if we are going to
be able to have more people go to work
we need child care it's always about the
children for me
so again we'll be meeting this afternoon
and i will once again make the
offer will come down a trillion you go
up a trillion and then we can
have we'll be within range of of each
other
but again this is a very different set
of values across the table
trickle down bubble up
the distinguished leader from the senate
mr schumer now i am bubbling up
well thank you whoops sorry
thank you very much speaker once again
for your strong passionate and eloquent
leadership
let me just say we saw the jobs report
and it's clear the economy is losing
steam
that means we need big bold investments
in america to help average folks
and when the economy starts losing
ground
the only choice is for a strong package
and yet at times yesterday our
republican friends seem willing to walk
away from the negotiating table
to do an unworkable weak and narrow
executive orders which are not going to
do the job for the american people
we are committed to negotiating
and as we said we are willing to make
compromises
we we our bill the hero's bill is at
three four theirs is it one
so the speaker made a very fair offer
let's narrow it each and you should have
seen the vehemence no
i said you mean after she said we'll go
down a trillion you go up a trillion
we didn't specify where or when and it's
mainly in terms of
dates but that's okay and you should
have seen their faces absolutely not i
said you mean we
you want it to go almost all in your
direction or you won't negotiate and
they said
yeah so we
are trying to compromise the spin that
they're putting it on that we haven't
moved off is be lied by what happened
they're the ones stuck and they say
basically what's happening is
mr meadows is from the tea party you
have 20 republicans in the senate
greatly influenced by them
and they don't want to spend the
necessary dollars to help get america
out of this mess
ideology sort of blinds them
so we need a bill there are only really
two choices
for our republican negotiating friends
they can do a strong bill
with democrats and they have to realize
they're going to need a majority they're
going to need all the democrats to vote
for it in the house
and a majority of democrats to vote for
it in the senate they don't have the
votes in the senate
so that means they've got to meet us
in terms of moving they can't just say
no and do it our way
or their other choice is to do some weak
insufficient
executive orders that just won't do the
job for the people we all want to help
it's not that the executive orders might
be negative but they're totally
insufficient
they're insufficient in two ways what
they do
is difficult because in because it seems
and no one knows what they're going to
do
but they can't spend money they can only
forward money
so if you do a payroll tax cut then
after
whatever after it expires both
businesses and workers have a huge
payment to make
you do unemployment and you lend the
state's money
they're stuck they don't have the money
they may not want to do it
in terms of tenants
yeah delaying evictions is necessary but
not sufficient
because once those once the delay is
over
the tenant owes a tremendous amount of
money and by the way the landlord many
of whom are small little landlords
haven't gotten paid and they can't pay
their mortgages and their bills
and there's a fourth one
and the college loans again is deferral
so you don't pay for a few months and
then you have more to pay it is much
better
and our colleagues admitted that
yesterday to do a strong robust bill but
they seem unable but the biggest problem
with the executive orders is not what
they do but who they leave out
they leave out testing tracing treatment
we know we're not going to solve this
problem economically until we solve the
health problem and speaker's been
like a lioness i guess i should say or a
lion
is lioness okay has been like a lioness
in pursuing this at every meeting we
have been at
and you're not going to cure that you're
not going to solve the problem
they still seem unwilling to do what is
necessary
for a strong testing tracing and
treatment regime
what is one of the biggest problems
facing us in the next month as the
speaker mentions schools
opening up the schools safely if you
don't open up the schools
you're going to hurt the economy
significantly because lots of people
can't go to work
executive orders leave out schools all
together
state and local services they came a
tiny little bit in our direction on that
but very little
not in the middle we're close to it
you can't do that by executive order
it's spending and you'll have
firefighters this is not abstract
this is not government it is
firefighters sanitation workers bus
drivers health care workers
who need to get paid elections
i got very excited or firm
at the meeting yesterday this is the
wellspring of our democracy it's not
much money
we need the money to help the states in
covid conduct elections when so much
more is going to be by mail and even
when you vote in person you need more
polling places
why are they resisting it's a small
amount we've asked for 3.6 billion
dollars in the um
heroes act it's not the money they
almost seem they don't want elections to
be conducted
in a full way as possible they seem that
they want certain people not to almost
discouraging them from being able to
vote
the post office
there was uh a lot of discussion on that
and frankly we have little faith that
they're not trying to politicize the
post office and we need language and
legislation to prevent that from
happening because again it's not the
abstract they don't like having a
government post office i guess some of
them
but it's people getting their medicines
it's during covert a greater reliance on
it and it's elections
if the ballots are not sent quickly
enough
if both the absentee ballots the
application for mail ballots
and the ballots themselves are delayed
too much we won't have a fair election
we talked about food assistance
they do not want to do what's needed to
make sure kids and others don't go
hungry
we talked about utility shutoffs
if you're going to have a moratorium on
rent but people can't pay their electric
bills or their water bills their homes
aren't
that good
so and we talked about targeted aid
for our communities of color so many
things are left out
so the bottom line is this is a flood
economically and health-wise a biblical
proportion and our republican friends
are looking like
they just want to fix a leaky faucet
that's what's the difference here
there are real needs america knows they
have real needs the public is on our
side
but they would seem not to be willing to
go in a direction
that would meet those needs and instead
do executive orders that won't come
close to doing
the job that is needed speaker
as the leader was speaking i was
thinking of the chairman of the fed and
the ammunition he has given us to think
big and they're doing a lot to shore up
the stock market
and that's probably a good thing for the
economy why can't they do
more to shore up america's working
families
this is uh the numbers this morning
should be a real cl uh cautionary
call to them to say the momentum
is the amendment which sprang from
government
investment from what we did in the
previous bills
that kept the economy going that people
would have money in their pockets
would have consumer competence would
spend a jet inject demand into
the economy create jobs
we see that slowing down
everybody who talks to us from in the
economic world and all the rest are
saying
pay now or pay later this is
you're going to pay more later you're
going to pay more later you
absolutely must have to think in a big
way
as we go through all this and you know i
sometimes quote
saint augustine or um paul or
somebody pope paul vi one thing that i
was thinking of as you were speaking mr
leader
arnold toynbee arnold twanbe in his
histories of civilization as you are
aware of
he said that when societies are formed
there are two ways they can go the elite
minority that will be ruling could be
there
called the flowering elite there for the
flowering
of everybody in that society or
they could be the exploitive elites
the exploited minorities and they are
there for
power and money power and money and when
these two
exist in the same society there's
can be a schism of the soul of the
society
because they're so different that's kind
of what we're at that table
about we're there representing the
kitchen table needs
kitchen table needs of the american
people they're there representing the
board
conference room table and that is a
different
perspective and that's why it takes
longer now it takes a great deal
and i salute my colleagues because they
have been very courageous
because the other side is going out
there making it like they're there for
children and
and people in new working families
which couldn't be further from the truth
and nothing gives more evidence to it
than how they are conducting this so
again will we believe we have a
responsibility to try to find common
ground
you come to we'll come down a trillion
you go up a trillion
and we can figure out how we do that
without hurting
america's working families it's mostly
about how long
the initiatives last that it's not about
different priorities it's just about
shorter periods of time
we have a moral responsibility to find
common ground
but where we can't for the children
we must stand our ground yes ma'am
speaker police were first yesterday too
fantastic i like it so
republicans have been saying that
democrats
are not willing to give anything so now
you're saying you're willing to come
down a tree said that yes you said it
last night
they didn't bring it up but they said
they heard it and rejected it
and they weren't telling the truth when
they said that right so you're willing
to come down to 2.4 trillion
or less and also congressman congressman
meadows
when he was a member when he was a
congressman he was always he was a tea
party
freedom caucus someone who was there to
block deals
do you think that he is negotiating in
good faith
i certainly hope so we just have to
assume that his positions
his positions are quite hardened and
non-compromising
more so than mnuchin
and 2.4 trillion you're willing to come
together
nancy said we'll go down a trillion from
our top number
which we and they'll go up a trillion
and they rejected it totally we didn't
go over specific numbers where it's from
but their original is it one
our original you could say is it three
four or three seven depending on how you
treat the tax stuff yeah see
in our bill we subtract uh we take away
repealed the the uh over
it's a 135 billion dollar um
tax advantage they gave the wealthiest
people in our country
in the cares act so we repealed that but
not only that we broadened the repeal of
some other things as well so we have
about 250
in there now if they don't want to
repeal that
then our bill is like two seven three
three excuse me
three seven
here when you talk about chad three
trillion two trillion or whatever the
number is in the middle here
i mean what are some of the specific
things that you have pitched to your
caucus things that were in that bill
that you passed
okay this is gonna have to take a hit
this is gonna have to take a hit
well no it's only about some of the
things we have in there go to september
30
september 30th 2021 we can adjust the
date
yes sir so uh
the house doesn't have the votes to go
south of 2 trillion the senate democrats
can't go south of 2 trillion
so that's what compromise is all about
because
there are 20 republicans who don't want
to vote for anything that doesn't mean
the whole thing should shift in their
direction
you have to meet in the middle what i
have said
is we have a virus when we did cares
the anticipation and the hope was that
they would eventually pay attention to
science
and this would be diminishing instead
it's accelerating
this virus is like a freight train
coming so fast and they're responding
like a convoy going as slow as the
slowest
ship it just now doesn't work and what
we put in our bill is what we
saw as necessary necessary
to save the lives of the american people
the livelihoods of the american people
and the life of our democracy and i'll
say it over and over and this is not
sorry this is i'll leave this in my
pocket this is not just a numerical
game i mean you're acting like oh no
this is feeding kids opening schools
employing people helping people who need
help
this is having fair elections these are
very substantive
things to us and we will try to meet
them somewhere so we can get something
done
but it's not just oh they want this you
want that and
it's real needs that's what guides us
what seems to guide them
is the idea the government should spend
as little money as possible despite the
crisis in america
and what that means is that as i said
last night to some of you
it's about sophie's choice who are we
going to choose if we're not going to
have enough money
to feed everyone if we're not going to
have enough money to house
people if we're if we're not giving
money to the schools
in a way and by the way let's just talk
about the schools for a moment because
when the president says he's going to
have the bulk of his money go
to schools that open that are
in person actual we say uh but not to
the the others
many of those virtual or or
hybrid schools are in neighborhoods that
don't have a high tax brace
so when the president says we're cutting
you out
they're cutting out kids and
title 1 kids in economically
disadvantaged areas
children of color and and some of those
areas
so that's why we have to say wait a
minute this is for all of america's
children
it just doesn't lucky you
coronavirus came along you lived in a
high-end
property tax area and poor you
just reinforcing reinforcing the
disparity
in terms of meeting those children's
needs reinforcing the disparity
in terms of of how we address the
coronavirus
where a high percentage of the deaths
now are
clearly evidence that they are springing
from communities of color so
there's so many injustices in here
and again in order to just say all of
the children
should be protected whether it's from
the virus
or at home or in school anyone else with
that yes
do we do three yeah
will democrats want to continue
negotiations on other issues he
mentioned that these executive orders
leave out testing other issues is that
an area where you'd be willing to
negotiate
if and when he does it we'll let you
know thank you you